all listening units possible shots fired
at the elementary school we got a call
from a guy saying he's walking into the
school threatening to shoot all the
kids was that Aspen Elementary Aspen
Elementary
School give me more when he got it did
sound like shots might have been fired
in the
background what was going through my
mind is this is my my disaster as the
sheriff
on the morning of February 22nd 2023 the
Pitkin County Dispatch Center in Aspen
Colorado received a phone call about an
active
shooter armed police were immediately
sent to the
scene my son could see the SWAT team
with like machine guns and assault
rifles like running around
outside and so he was sure that somebody
was coming you know to shoot them and he
thought he was going to die that
day get
inside in America fear of school
shootings is
widespread today that fear is being
weaponized by hoax callers claiming they
are about to attack a school we have act
shooter call here
yeah is anything that's going on these
calls are often called SWAT hoaxes
because they require the response of a
full special weapons and tactics or SWAT
team there are no solid data on how
often these happen but reports of hoaxes
in the media suggest they're
increasing in the 2018 school year there
were around 70 in 2022 there were
450 that's 10 times the number of
incidents when a gun was actually fired
on school property during school
hours for 6 months The Economist has
been investigating these incidents to
try to find out why they are proving so
difficult to
stop that took us to Aspen Colorado and
the county sheriff's
office in February they received one of
these
calls we have deputies and officers
whose children go to those schools it
was very difficult they're running into
a school where their child is in
possible danger9 I'm in the high school
park within about 30 minutes we realized
that it was a hoax or swatting call but
was real until it wasn't it was very
real this is Aspen Elementary School
just over a minute after the call came
through Aspen Police were on the scene
they sent 15 officers all told 44
officers from the surrounding area 26
firefighters and 27 Medics descended on
the
school this was probably one of the
largest responses I've ever seen as a
law enforcement officer it was the
largest
response the school was locked down
Cheryl's son was one of around 500
children inside
there's SWAT teams running around
outside hey guys you head back down to
the parking lot he very legitimately
thought that there was someone in the
school you know coming to shoot
them Aspen Elementary was not the only
school to go through this in
February there were a total of 148 hoax
calls made that month often several per
day
on February 8th in Vermont there were
21 on the 15th in Massachusetts there
were at least
13 in Colorado on the 22nd there were
17 the first call came in at Alamosa at
8:24 Aspen's call came through shortly
after the calls were made to police
departments in almost alphabetical order
and didn't stop until 1:45
audio of the calls The Economist has
studied shows they came from the same
voice working off a script I have an
AR-15 and P bombs with me AR-15 and P
bombs with me AR15 and P
bombs the fact that this attack was so
well orchestrated suggests this was more
than just prank kohs I personally feel
this is an act of domestic terrorism to
do this was was an intentional plot to
terrorize
people in her career as an FBI
intelligence analyst Jen dobler
investigated numerous swatting
incidents working out of New York City
after 9/11 we experienced swatting on a
fairly regular basis where we would get
calls in saying there was a pipe bomb on
the El train or there is a man with a
bomb in his shoe coming in on the next
American Airlines
flight
but today's swatting calls are different
the majority of cases of swatting that I
have seen are not a disgruntled
individual sitting in their basement
calling from a landline the incidents
that we're seeing today are um extremely
high
tech some swatters advertise their
services on the dark web asking to be
paid in
cryptocurrency AI is sometimes used to
generate fake voices on phone calls
all of this can make tracking down us
water incredibly
difficult at the start of an
investigation the only thing law
enforcement has to go on is the initial
phone call and that can give us some
Clues police reports The Economist has
looked at reveal the Colorado caller
used at least two phone numbers both
have a Southwest Florida area code but
the caller wasn't necessarily in Florida
when one dispatcher redialed the number
they reached this voicemail the Tex now
subscriber you were trying to reach is
not available text now is a viip or
voice over Internet Protocol service it
allows phone numbers to be created over
the Internet when doing this it's
possible for a swatter to use a virtual
private Network or VPN to disguise where
their call is coming from previous
investigations have traced swatters to
places all all over the
globe the Colorado case is being
investigated by the FBI which declined
to comment on the Call's
Origins but some features of the
Colorado caller give us Clues as to who
they might
be what is your
name it's
Nelson the name Nelson is um in and of
itself is a little bit interesting um
because there were two very very
successful swatters who are currently
Behind Bars one is James mccardy who's
known as aspan online and then another
one is Kaia Nelson who was known as
chumo like the Colorado caller this team
usually claimed to have an AR-15 and
pipe bums I don't believe that that is
just in and of itself a coincidence
especially if they use the name Nelson
this has to be my opinion someone who
has some sort of knowledge about Chum L
and Ken
Nelson
today the fight back against SWAT hoaxes
is ramping
up in the summer of 2023 SWAT hoaxes
were made a felony in
Colorado 15 other states have done the
same the FBI is Now tracking these calls
and some think the call service
providers should also be better policed
when you have a singular user that
creates an account from a VPN and all of
a sudden is making 10 calls in a
5-minute span to different
numbers there should be some sort of hey
maybe we're going to shut this account
down we reached out to Tex now during
the course of our investigation they
said Tex Now does not condone the use of
our platform for swatting harassment
fraud or other illegal activity that
jeopardizes Public Safety and since May
they have taken steps to stop Bad actors
from using the service such as disabling
the ability to make calls from a web
browser when connected via
VPN these hoaxes may not make the news
in the same way a shooting does door
propped
open but the trauma suffered by children
and teachers can still take a long time
to heal I'm really thankful that it was
a hoax and it wasn't real but you know
emotionally I think there's there still
a toll and I know there was a lot of
kids at school that you know that were
really affected by it
if the trend continues many more schools
parents and children could suffer the
same thank you for watching this
investigation into SWAT hookes was just
one part of a much bigger investigation
The Economist has been working on if you
click the link you'll be able to read
that reporting in the meantime don't
forget to
subscribe